[Música]
el presidente estadounidense Joe biden
visitó Puerto Rico por motivo del
huracán Fiona que tiene a la isla en
crisis de servicios desde el pasado 19
de septiembre los habitantes han
criticado duramente a la casa blanca
porque los fondos de recuperación no
cubren toda la población y porque han
tardado en llegar
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken fue recibido en
Bogotá por el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro tras sostener una reunión
privada del funcionario dijo en rueda de
prensa que su país apoya un nuevo
enfoque integral de lucha contra las
drogas ante críticas de Petro que tacha
de obsoleta y fracasada la estrategia
actual
quien organizaciones mexicanas
defensoras de la libertad de prensa
denunciaron que el ejército o el
gobierno de Andrés Manuel López Obrador
continúan usando el software de
espionaje pegasus contra activistas de
derechos humanos Esto Pese a que el
mandatario prometió erradicar esas
acciones cuando fue elegido Tenemos
reporte desde Ciudad de México
Estas son las noticias de América en
Francia 24 y comenzamos en la visita del
presidente de estadounidense Joe biden a
Puerto Rico para evaluar los daños
causados por el huracán Fiona que tocó
la isla del pasado 19 de septiembre los
habitantes se reclamaron la falta de
apoyo por parte del gobierno
estadounidense cuando han sido afectados
por desastres naturales en el pasado el
mandatario también visitará el estado de
Florida el miércoles y se espera que
allí anuncie ayudas para hacer frente a
la devastación y que dejó el huracán Ian
el informe es de Manuela Cano no los
olvidamos Ese es el mensaje que el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
Busca mandar en su visita Puerto Rico
después de más de dos semanas de que el
huracán a tocar a la isla el mandatario
llegó al suelo el territorio libre
asociado para evaluar los daños y
anunciar ayudas por 60 millones de
dólares
venimos aquí en persona para demostrar
que estamos con ustedes todo Estados
Unidos está con ustedes mientras me
reciben recuperan y reconstruyen Confío
en que podemos hacer todo lo que usted
quiera gobernador y estoy comprometido
con esta isla
la visita de biden llega 5 años después
del huracán María que devastó la isla en
una tragedia que según muchos
puertorriqueños no tuvo la respuesta
adecuada por parte de la entonces
administración de Donald Trump el miedo
de una situación similar se repite ahora
con Fiona que causó la muerte de al
menos 25 personas y dejó a la isla sin
electricidad unos daños que Siguen sin
revertirse por completo a un cerca del
10% sigue sin energía
al lado de Fiona Ian los daños del
huracán que tocó Florida como categoría
4 siguen apareciendo los equipos de
rescate han reportado que han visitado
45.000 hogares y negocios en las áreas
afectadas y los fallecidos ya son casi
un centenar las labores de rescate y de
restauración de la energía continúan en
este momento en todo el estado 95% de
los clientes tienen electricidad
hasta ahora hemos tenido más de 1900
rescates con los equipos de la unidad de
búsqueda y rescate que han ido puerta a
Puerta de 65 diferentes edificaciones
Florida espera la llegada de byden el
miércoles una en la que el mandatario
evaluará los daños en primera persona y
se espera que anuncien nuevas medidas
hacia la reconstrucción del Estado
el secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken visitó Colombia
en rueda de prensa conjunta del
presidente Gustavo Petro repitió que la
guerra contra las drogas liderada por
Washington ha sido un fracaso Y una vez
más pidió un nuevo enfoque internacional
en el concordancia blinken respondió que
su país apoya firmemente el enfoque
integral para frenar el narcotráfico que
impulsa el actual gobierno también
acordaron intensificar la interceptación
de sustancias ilegales en el mar y
mejorar el intercambio de inteligencia
sobre narcotráfico
la política represiva sobre el
narcotráfico no va sobre el campesinado
va sobre los dueños del narcotráfico
para esto necesitamos dos grandes
instrumentos vuelvo a repetirlo
y es un tema de conversación con los
Estados Unidos uno el incremento de la
capacidad de interdicción
fundamentalmente marítima
complementariamente aérea del país
Es decir de tener la droga cuando sale
y dos
aumentar la capacidad inteligencia para
capturar Los Dueños del narcotráfico en
el país
estamos invirtiendo en la prevención
contra el abuso de sustancias en el
tratamiento y la recuperación para
quienes padecen de adicción en nuestros
países y más allá para reducir el daño
que causan las drogas ilícitas y para
reducir la demanda particularmente en
Estados Unidos que genera tanta
actividad criminal que Define nuestra
sociedad a lo largo de cada prioridad
compartida vamos ahora a México allí
grupos dedicados a promover la libertad
de prensa denunciaron que el gobierno o
el ejército mexicano siguen usando el
software espía pegasus para piratear los
teléfonos celulares de los activistas
esto a pesar de la promesa del
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
de poner fin al espionaje las denuncias
citan evidencia de intentos recientes de
utilizar el programa de spyware israelí
contra activistas quienes investigan
abusos contra los Derechos Humanos por
parte del ejército mexicano la infección
de pegasus fue confirmada desde 2019 y
2020 a de una investigación forense que
fue realizada por el grupo citizenlaf de
la Universidad de Toronto vamos a ver
los detalles de esta nueva denuncia con
nuestro corresponsal en Ciudad de México
Mario carbonell
Hola Así es son tres organizaciones las
que anunciaron que presentarán una
denuncia ante la fiscalía general de la
república se trata de artículo 19 la red
en defensa de los Derechos digitales y
amnistía internacional que denuncian
precisamente este espionaje por parte
del ejército contra dos periodistas
Ricardo Rafael uno más del portal animal
político cuyo nombre se mantiene en
reserva así como un defensor de Derechos
Humanos Raymundo Ramos en Tamaulipas
señalaron que están conscientes de que
es muy probable que no avancen estas
investigaciones en la fiscalía pues ya
llevan más de cinco años que presentaron
otras denuncias por espionaje con
pegasos correspondientes al sexenio de
Peña Nieto y no hay aún Claridad al
respecto señaló por ejemplo Daniel
Moreno el director del portal animal
político que la infiltración al celular
de uno de sus reporteros no nada más lo
afecta a él sino que dañó toda la
redacción y pues tiene ahí las bases de
datos y toda la información que venían
trabajando Raymundo Ramos el defensor de
Derechos Humanos lamentó que el gobierno
se dedique a investigar a activistas y
no a los criminales a los que debería
estar siguiéndoles la pista
señalaron Esto bueno también Ricardo
Rafael uno de los aludidos o uno de los
de las víctimas
lamentó que no nada más es él sino
también su hijo menor de 12 años quien
Pues fue víctima de este espionaje con
pegasus ya comprobado con el citizenlab
con sede en Toronto tenemos más noticias
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump fue demandó a CNN por difamación
pidió 475 millones de dólares en daños
punitivos alegando que la cadena
informativa llevó a cabo una campaña de
calumnias e injurias en su contra la
demanda consignada en Florida asegura
que CNN usó su influencia como de
noticias líder para derrotarlo
políticamente son 29 páginas de denuncia
que replican un largo historial de
críticas o contra él pero hay un
especial enfoque en presuntos ataques
que habrían sucedido en los últimos
meses porque la cadena temía Que
volviera a postularse para presidente en
el año 2024
más de 2000 soldados y policías rodearon
y cerraron el pueblo de comasagua en El
Salvador esto para buscar pandilleros
acusados de asesinato una nueva acción
en el estado de emergencia que ya suma
seis meses he promovido por el
presidente nayib bukele en el marco de
su política de mano dura criticada por
grupos de Derechos Humanos pero
aplaudida por la población que le da
altos índices de aprobación justamente
el mandatario dijo que creía que
miembros de La Pandilla ms-13 aún
estaban dentro de comasagua ubicada a
unos 30 kilómetros al sureste de la
capital San Salvador
y para el cierre del presidente de Chile
Gabriel borich anunció la creación del
nuevo Parque Nacional del desierto
florido en la región de atacama esto
para proteger el área e impulsar el
turismo la zona es especial por el
fenómeno de floración cuando hay altas
precipitaciones más altas de lo normal y
se convertirá en la número 44 del país
que es oficialmente protegida las flores
de atacama el desierto más seco y
también el más soleado del mundo aparece
en cada 3 a 5 años cuando la arena se
cubre con un colorido manto morado todo
gracias al despliegue natural de unas
200 especies
recuerde que la ampliación de esta y
otras noticias está en nuestro sitio web
France 24.com siga con nosotros volvemos
con más
[Música]